cody and i are divorced
we're completely separate
sister wife star christine brown getting
real about her decision to end her
marriage to cody every single day of my
life i wake up and i have a choice to
make if i'm in a situation like that and
in the end i would love to just be
strong and be like no no no no and just
cause more contention more contention
more contention or i can just go okay
okay that's fine that's fine that's fine
and make it easier but in the end i lose
myself during part two of the sister
wives season 16 tell-all christine
reveals how her split is affecting the
other wives mary janelle and robin it's
not fun breaking people's hearts
i mean at my core
i just want people to be happy and i
just want people to feel loved but i
knew i was making a decision that would
break hearts and it tore me apart and it
was super super sad while christine is
seemingly firm in her decision cody mary
janelle and robin are struggling with
the idea which isn't a huge surprise
he's spoken to e.t about this before
i'm not in a place where i i say hey to
a wife i'm leaving you that's just never
going to happen
um it's just not you know
if if our relationship isn't good then
we either figure out how to work it out
or or whatever so
is we we don't allow the d word in the
house
well not out of my mouth necessarily
it's not a d word it's a work it out
you know it's a figure out
i just don't know why they're not
figuring this stuff out
and talking and
finding their compromise it's my family
for me to have like a
someone else tell me whether or not my
marriage is over i'm like no
i don't really need that the current
dynamic between the wives has left
christine feeling like a quote basement
wife a term used to describe someone in
the family who's considered less
important than the other wives and she
says that mentality changed what it
feels like to live in this plural
marriage i didn't know at that time
about basement wives i didn't know that
it was anything i had no idea i chose
but the digest let it happen and i chose
to be weaker i just did i didn't know
she felt that way and i felt like
janelle and maybe even mary weren't like
they were like well we'll just deal with
the dysfunction or the things that don't
work and christine was just like going
i'm not gonna do it. christine and cody
announced they were ending their
spiritual marriage after 25 years
together back in november cody is only
legally married to his fourth wife robin
mary i can't do marriage with cody
anymore i don't want him you don't get
to give up like that i don't want to do
it anymore
this season's finale gave a little more
insight into their split the intimate
part of our marriage is over
and
to be honest
i'm not
okay with that
i'm not okay with staying in a marriage
where there's no intimacy that's not a
real marriage i'm not interested in a
half marriage
or a partial marriage or whatever we
have it's seemingly been a long time
coming the pair hasn't lived together
during the pandemic and christine
actually told et that gaining some
independence in that time showed her the
life she wants to live i like my own
space i like my own autonomy i feel like
i like me better now as and i just feel
like i've been able to
really
like raise my kids how i want to i
really have more of an independence and
i really i just
think the autonomy is really really nice
and i feel like as a person that i do
better with a little bit more distance
i put
everybody first most of the time i put
whatever cody needed it's like i can be
the peacemaker here what do you need
what does janelle need what does mario
need what do all the kids need it left
me running on empty and i asked him for
help i'm like i can't do this anymore